THIS IS "THE FIVE."
ELIZABETH WARREN CLAIMS SHE'S
PART NATIVE AMERICAN APPEARS TO
BE BACKFIREING
THE CHEROKEE NATION IS REJECTING
THE RESULTS LAYING CLAIM TO THE
CHEROKEE NATION OR TRIBAL NATION
IS INAPPROPRIATE AND WRONG.
SENATOR WARREN IS UNDERMINING
HER INTERESTS WITH HER CLAIMS.
AND ANOTHER MEMBER IS ACCUSING
WARREN OF PLAYING POLITICS.
>> SHE HAS RELIED ON STEREOTYPES
AND POPULAR MISCONCEPTIONS ABOUT
NATIVE AMERICANS TO PROP UP HER
FALSE CLAIMS.
I THINK HER DECISION SHOWED SHE
DOES NOT LISTEN TO NATIVE PEOPLE
AND IS MORE CONCERNED ABOUT HER
OWN POLITICAL CAREER AND
AMBITION THAN TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY
AND RIGHTS.
>> AND STORIES HAVE TURNED OUT
TO BE A SCAM AND A LIE AFTER HE
CALLED ON THE SENATOR TO SAY
SORRY FOR PREVIOUS CLAIMS.
>> SHE OWES THE COUNTRY AN
APOLOGY.
HER CLAIM IS NOT SOMETHING I
ENJOY TO DO.
>> THE REST OF THE PARTY LOOKS
TO PUT THIS ISSUE IN THE
REARVIEW MIRROR AHEAD OF THE
MIDTERMS.
>> SHE'S PUT TO REST HIS
INAPPROPRIATE SUGGESTIONS USING
HIS NICKNAME FOR HER THAT
SOMEHOW SHE DIDN'T KNOW HER OWN
FAMILY HISTORY AND IT'S BEST FOR
EVERYBODY IF WE MOVE ON AND
UNDERSTAND IT'S ANOTHER EPISODE
BENEATH THE PRESIDENT.
>> MOVE ON?
NOT YET.
JESSE, YOU HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE
TO COMMENT.
>> Jesse: AS YOU REMEMBER I HAD
MY DNA TESTED AND I'M .9% BLACK.
I'M MORE BLACK THAN SHE IS
INDIAN AND IMAGINE IF I ALL OF A
SUDDEN STARTED CLAIMING I WAS
BLACK AND LISTED AS A MINORITY
AND FOX NEWS LISTED ME AS A
MEMBER OF THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION.
THIS IS WHAT ELIZABETH WARREN
DID.
SHE SAID SHE WAS A WOMAN OF
COLOR.
SHE'S WHITE.
SHE WAS CLAIMING TO BE A
MINORITY.
SHE SAID SHE WAS A CHEROKEE IN
THE COOKBOOK SHE WROTE.
SHE SAID HER PARENTS WERE
OPPRESSED BECAUSE HER MOTHER WAS
CHEROKEE AND ALL OF A SUDDEN THE
CHEROKEE NATION IS LIKE, NO,
YOU'RE NOT A MEMBER OF TRIBE.
SORRY.
IT'S COMING UNRAVELLED AND THE
PEOPLE MORE EXCITED ABOUT THIS
THAN DONALD TRUMP IS JOE
SANDERS.
SHE'S COOKED AS A CANDIDATE AND
I WATCHED IT UNFOLD YESTERDAY
BECAUSE I HAD THE SNIFFLES AN
SHE CAME OUT AND FELT SHE SCORED
AT FIRST AND SO DID THE MEDIA
AND THEY DEMANDED DONALD TRUMP
PAYOFF THE MILLION-DOLLAR DEBT
AND NOW SHE'S AT WAR WITH THE
CHEROKEE NATION AND THE DNA
GAMBLE MAY HAVE BACKFIRED.
REMEMBER THE BIRTH CERTIFICATE
WITH BARACK OBAMA.
IMAGINE HE GETS IT AND IT'S NOT
UP TO SNUFF.
DO YOU THINK HE WOULD HAVE THEN
PUT IT OUT?
SHE GOT THE RESULTS AND IT'S
1/1,000 AND THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
A WINNING MOVE AND I'M ASTONISH.
>> THE MENTION OF THE BIRTH
CERTIFICATE IS TIMELY BECAUSE
IT'S THE SAME MOVE AND HE
FORCED -- HE FORCES HER TO TAKE
THE TEST AND GETS THE GUY TO SAY
YOU HAVE SOME AMERICAN INDIAN
ANCESTRY AND THEN WON'T PAY HER
AND THEN INSULTS HER BY -- IT'S
KIND OF A SEXUAL SUGGESTION I'M
GOING TO PERSONALLY TEST YOU BUT
I WON'T ENJOY IT.
>> Jesse: HOW DO YOU DO THAT?
>> Juan: IT'S SO TI
>> Juan: IT'S SO TYPICAL OF
TRUMP.
SHE WAS DONE WHAT WAS ASKED.
>> Jesse: THE WON THE BET?
>> Juan: ALL HE SAID WAS IF YOU
HAVE INDIAN ANCESTRY I'LL GIVE
YOU $1 MILLION.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
THAT'S WHAT HE ASKED AND WHAT
SHE DID.
THE LIGHT THE CHEROKEE NATION IS
SAYING YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE
THIS IS ABOUT TRIBAL
AFFILIATION.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
BLOOD TEST.
YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION.
>> Jesse: WHY AM I WORRIED ABOUT
THAT?
>> Dana: WHEN IT TURNS TO
RIDICULE YOU MAY HAVE A
POLITICAL WINNER IF YOU'RE GOING
AGAINST ELIZABETH WARREN.
LOOK AT THE TWEET FROM ORAN
HATCH.
HE MAKES FUN OF HIS AGE IN HIS
80s AND SAID DNA ARE QUITE
SOMETHING AND HE HAS A T-REX.
>> Greg: VERY FUNNY.
IT'S MUE HILL IATING.
YOU DON'T -- YOU MILL IATING.
YOU DON'T
HUMILIATING.
THIS MAKES MICHAEL DE
THIS MAKES MICHAEL DUKAKIS LIKE
TEAR DOWN THE WALL.
IN MY MIND SHE'S COOKED.
SHE HAS MORE IN COMMON WITH THE
JEEP THAN WITH THE TRIBE AND
THAT'S WHY THEY KICKED HER OFF
THE RESERVATION.
IT WAS INSULTING TO THEM THAT
SHE FOR THE SECOND TIME WAS
EXPLOITING NATIVE AMERICANS FOR
HER OWN ADVANCEMENT.
FIRST IN COLLEGE AND NOW THIS
AND THEY KNEW IT AND IT
DISGUSTED THEM AND TRUMP DOESN'T
OWE HER ANYTHING.
IF SHE'S INDIAN HE DIDN'T SAY
PART BUT IF SHE'S INDIAN.
IF MOST AMERICANS HAVE MORE
NATIVE AMERICAN BLOOD THAN SHE
DOES BUT THIS IS BEFORE WHERE
IDENTITY POLITICS TAKES YOU AND
WHEN AU PLY FOR A JOB -- YOU
APPLY FOR A JOB WHERE DIVERSITY
TRUMPS EXPERIENCE THEY SHOULD
STAPLE YOUR DNA TEST TO YOUR SAT
SCORE AND APPLICATION AND THAT
WILL KILL ALL OF THIS.
>> Juan: LET'S GET BEYOND THE
STATIC AND GOSSIP.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS THE WHITE
IDENTITY -- I'M TALKING ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP PREYING ON WHITE
WOMAN.
>> SHE BENEFITTED.
>> THIS IS THE ULTIMATE CULTURAL
APPROPRIATION BY ELIZABETH
WARREN.
IT'S SO MUCH WORSE AND SHE
BENEFITTED OFF OF IT FOR 30
YEARS BY LISTING HERSELF IN
THESE DIRECTORIES THAT SAID SHE
WAS NATIVE AMERICAN WHICH WERE
USED AS HEAD HUNTER PORTFOLIOS
FOR SCHOOLS LIKE HARVARD LAW TO
LOOK AT LISTS OF PEOPLE WHO WERE
INTERESTED IN GETTING MORE
DIVERSITY INTO THEIR LAW
SCHOOLS.
>> Juan: SOME OF THE SCHOOLS MAY
HAVE SAID THAT --
>> IT'S A BENEFIT TO ELIZABETH
WARREN.
>> SHE DID A VIDEO EXPLOITING
NATIVE AMERICANS.
WHY DID SHE SEEK OUT THE
STANFORD ACADEMIC ANYWAY INSTEAD
OF USING A COMMERCIAL PRODUCT
LIKE WE DID ON "THE FIVE"?
SHE NEEDED AN ALLY.
>> Juan: THE GUY'S AN EXPERT.
>> IS HE AN EXPERT WHEN HE
DIDN'T EVEN TEST THE PROPER DNA.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
>> Dana: LAST WORD TO JESSE AND
THE TIMING IS TERRIBLE.
WILL ANYBODY LET THIS GO?
>> Jesse: DEMOCRATS ARE
COMPLAINING SHE DIDN'T NEED TO
DO THIS NOW THREE WEEKS BEFORE
THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS.